I think I love you're very attractive
you're single and you're always very
forward when you come on the show about
how you're you're on you're on the
lookout for the right guy
yes I am always looking yeah there are
some cuties out there yeah okay but
you're always on the lookout and then I
was think about this today I understand
very recently you met Chadwick Boseman
is that true yes I saw him at a
restaurant I was like oh my god he's
juicing yeah I like sex my friend I
think I gotta say something that you
were gonna go up to him oh absolutely I
got shoot my shot yeah so I went up to
him now she's like whoa you just a
tasted piece of chocolate you a real
treat and then he laughed and then he
had a very hot friend I was like damn
you're hot to a table and then they
politely laughed and then I sat there
and stared at them you might hear from
them you never know I mean Chadwick
where's the camera Chadwick there's a
lot of cameras yeah that was sad it was
sad that you were looking for Chad
okay so you know
you